[Music]
good morning and welcome to trevor
phillips on sunday live from labour
conference in brighton
i hope you haven't gotten rid of those
flared jeans in the lava lamp because
the 1970s and 80s seem to be back
lockdown made beards okay for hipsters
i'm still working on the afro now we
have cues for petrol a government
reversing at speed on its immigration
policy to let foreign hev drivers and
turkey pluckers back into the country
and here at labour party conference the
left and the unions have a moderate
leader on the rack again kierstarm
arrived in brighton hoping to force
through a change to the party's rules
that would block a far-left challenge
for the leadership
he failed
so load to chew over with your spam
fritters and black forest gato pop the
matias rose in the fridge
on our menu this morning
i'm joined by angela rayner the party's
deputy leader
the government pledges action to address
cues at the petrol pump
i'll ask the transport secretary grant
chaps whether he has a grip on the
supply crisis
the former shadow channel chancellor
john mcdonnell will be here to tell us
whether the spirit of corbynism is alive
and well in the labour party
was we'll speak to the general secretary
of unison christine mcnee near about uh
labor's relations with the trades unions
and what can be done to stop a winter
crisis in the health and social care
sectors
and the former labor cabinet minister
charles clark who experienced his
party's wilderness years in the 1980s
and the triumphant landslide of new
labor will give us his assessment on how
far away this labour leadership is from
power
first
the deputy leader of the labour party
good morning mr ray
um
if we can get past yesterday's business
for the moment
did
uh kia stammer talk to you about his
proposed rule changes before the
conference
of course yeah and he spoke to the trade
unions and many others about the
proposals that he felt that we needed to
have a conversation about and that's
normal in in conference period we're
we're not happy unless we're talking
about a rule amendment a reference back
or a compensating meeting that's just
the normal hust and tussle of what we do
at conference so yeah you know he wanted
that consultation he wanted that
discussion we had our nec which passed
and approved um some proposals that are
going to go to conference floor and
that's how we do things in the labour
party so uh
another labour party tradition
the two of you clearly didn't disagree
because you put forward a separate
amendment to his proposal at the nec
well i'm not going to discuss what
happened at the private meeting of the
nec that is the case but one of the
things that i'm concerned of and i
always have been and i've stood on the
platform is that we are able to
diversify our candidates and the way in
which we you know are able to you know
choose people as counselors as mayors as
as leaders and as myself as deputy
leader you know i wanted to make sure
that for example we're able to have more
women on the ballot and that we were
able to have more black asian and
minority ethnic candidates on the ballot
so my concerns around that is to make
sure that we don't inadvertently create
a problem for ourselves when we actually
want to have a broad base of candidates
on that ballot so that people can but if
the two of you were talking about it so
amicably that means he came into this
conference basically ignoring what you
wanted and the slogan for the party
conference says together um and the
future
how are people expected to believe that
you and kirsten are together for the
future when you can't even apparently
agree on the present well we did agree
you know we all agree we are in
agreement that well why did you have
this where did you feel
why did you feel the need to amend
what he put forward to the nec it wasn't
it was a tidying up of what was the same
thing that we were both trying to
achieve so it wasn't a it wasn't we call
them friendly amendments in the movement
is where you actually just try to tidy
up the wording because sometimes you
want to put something in and that's your
aim but the unintended consequences
sometimes have you know the ability to
disenfranchise and that was what we were
doing you know that's what my um
concerns were is that we continue to
make sure that we have a broad diverse
group of candidates that come forward so
that people can vote for that all right
one more piece of conference business
chair of the conference margaret beckett
when she opened yesterday talked about
civility so did the general secretary
david evans uh when he made his speech
um
you said last night we cannot get any
worse than a bunch of scum homophobic
racist misogynist
absolute pile of banana republic etonian
piece of scum
is that the kind of civility that the
star rainer labour party envisages
well look that was
post watershed as we'd say and with a
group of activists at an event last
night and and what i was trying to get
across
and this is the and it is my passionate
way in which i do it it's the anger
and frustration that people feel when
you have a prime minister who has said
things and not apologize them that are
racist that are misogynistic that are
homophobic
that has given billions of pounds of
taxpayers money to their mates and
literally wasted that money at a time
when they're cutting universal credit
plunging families into crisis and the
cost of living is going up then my
passion was about look we can't sit on
the sidelines here we have to get
organized and i was speaking to a group
of activists to say you've got to get
that fire in your belly the reason i was
so upset
about what the government did especially
on the school meals was because i was a
child that was hungry and i was a child
that needed that support and i remember
tory ministers at the time when i was 16
saying women like me girls like me at 16
were just getting pregnant to get
council houses so when the prime
minister uses language like calling
muslim women letter boxes that has an
effect and the fact that he hasn't
apologized for that then for me i don't
think he's fit to govern and i was
saying to a group of activists late at
night get your fire in your belly we
cannot sit on the sidelines anymore
we've got to get into power because
we've got to make things better for
ordinary working people in this country
look we can all get carried away but you
talked about a bunch of them you talked
about tories in general um
let me be clear i'm talking about
members of the cabinet so you've got the
home secretary who was bullied senior
civil servants okay reached the
ministerial code had private meetings
without civil servants okay president
and nothing's been done about that we've
have other cabinet members that have
said appalling things okay so i think
this government it's this government
we're being quite specific about who the
scum are or would you want to give me a
list of names well i think anyone who
leaves children hungry during a pandemic
and can give billions of pounds to their
mates on whatsapp i think that was
pretty scummy now that is a phrase and
let me contextualize it it's a phrase
that you would hear very often in
northern working-class towns that we
we'd even say it jovially to other
people you know we say it's a scummy
thing to do and that to me is my street
language as you would say about actually
it's pretty appalling that people think
that's okay to do yeah look i'm not
going to get into an argument about you
you you pride yourself on being plain
speaking and that's all fine
but
would you like to take this opportunity
perhaps to apologize to the 14 000
people in ashton underlying who voted
and the torii scum that you
describe
by suggesting and now you're suggesting
that somehow their choice
they made a choice
to be racist homophobic
and scummy let me be clear i am not
saying that anyone who voted for the
conservatives are racist scummy and
homophobic i'm saying the prime minister
do you just want to let's just steal it
why don't you apologize to the concert
those who voted conservative in ashland
on the line and by the way the millions
who voted conservative in those red wall
seats sure i'm satan and i'm very clear
i'm not saying anybody who voted
conservative are those things i'm saying
the prime minister
has said those things and has acted in
that way and if the prime minister wants
to apologize
and remove himself from those comments
that he's made that are homophobic that
are racist that are misogynistic then i
will apologize for calling himself okay
come on come on no i'm going to deal
with it you could just deal with it very
simply by saying i'm sorry
honestly i'm really serious about this
because i i feel really passionate about
the fact that when you've got a prime
minister of the country that thinks it's
okay to use the language that he's used
then that is appalling
scum
called i'm sorry is that is that this
ability that we're talking about now
because i've said that i'm very clear
that if the prime minister wants to
remove himself from those comments i'm
quite happy to apologize for calling him
scum all right if he wants to remove
himself from those comments the racist
misogynistic homophobic comments that
he's made very effective they're all
documented very offensive comments then
i will apologize to him personally for
calling himself if he wants to say that
he apologizes and doesn't mean the
comments that he's made in the past i'll
happily do that okay i'm sure he's
watching and he'll drop you a line let's
talk about policy you plan to legislate
to compel employers and unions to talk
to each other
what happens when the unions
and the employers disagree
well they go through the disputes
procedure there is a formal process for
them to do that you know it's well
documented but what this does actually
by having collective bargaining and
having that negotiation often they come
to agreement because employers and trade
unions have one common aim and that's
the business to flourish because without
the business you don't have the
membership and you don't have the
workers so what's new about this policy
employers and trade unions talk all the
time well what's new about this policy
of course in those sectors where we have
collective bargaining and i talk about
the social care sector and many social
care workers now do not have the
mechanism for fair pay agreements for
example and therefore i talk about how
that undercuts their wages 600 000 care
workers are not paid the minimum wage
they don't get you know i talked about
in my speech about how they don't get
travel time so i really want to increase
the standards in care so that people who
receive care get the best care but it's
great for business as well because staff
retention is a problem we know we've got
vacancies skills that we lose when you
have to skill people up again to do that
job actually it works better when you
pay people better i get all that but
you've christened this the new deal for
working people um let me remind you 200
2017 labor manifesto said that labour
would repeal the trade union act roll
out sector collective bargaining raise a
minimum wage at least 10 pounds a 2019
labor manifesto said that you would roll
out sexual collective bargaining across
the country bringing workers and
employers together to agree legal
minimum standards on a wide range of
issues that every employer would have to
adopt what exactly is new about the new
deal for working people well trevor i'm
consistent if nothing else to be fair
and then on top of that there's a suite
of other things that we announced so
we've done a lot of detailed work on
this the green paper that i produced
yesterday published has things like you
know rights from day one for all workers
talking about a single status for
workers so that we have the parental
leave that we have
rights for unfair dismissal from day one
and that people can get that support i
talked about flexible working people
joined the pandemic have worked more
flexibly than ever before homework and
other ways of working and i think we
should roll that out out and have an
opportunity for people to have more
flexibility and employers will benefit
from that in terms of all the different
sectors that we have across the whole of
the economy yeah look you
you're essentially recycling a policy
okay you can call it new if you like
this morning uh the leader has said that
uh he effectively wants to remove the
tax advantages that private schools
have this sort of feels
uh a bit like warmed up corbinism of
2017 and 2019. what is different about
the kier stama angela rayner leadership
from what was offered in 2019 well some
of our values stay the same trevor
throughout that's the labour party
that's what we've always been we've
always been a party of social justice
and about tackling inequality inequality
in the uk has grown under the
conservatives what we're saying is that
it's about priorities we shouldn't be
subsidizing private education when
you've got so many young people now who
haven't got those opportunities that
what we're saying is that money should
go back into supporting young people who
need that support and it's about
priorities and it's about showing the
difference between what a conservative
government does like that on the issue
of the tax hike on the issue of
universal credit and what we would do
completely different and our values are
about tackling inequality not just
saying it but tackling it let's let's
deal with the issue difference between
talking the talk and walking the walk um
is it embarrassing
that of the four biggest parties in
parliament now the labour party is the
only one that's never had a woman leader
well i i i did an interview recently at
the weekend and described um
care as a feminist and he is and you
know
but he's not a woman as far as i know
he's not a woman no but you know it's
about how you bring people forward and
about people putting their names forward
i hope we'll have a female leader one
day i'm absolutely committed to that
supporting somebody going forward or
taking that issue forward but care has
been very strong on supporting women and
i can only say as his deputy that the
first conversation i had with which was
a very serious one because if you
remember boris johnson was very poorly
at the time and i had covered and kir's
first conversation with me when we were
elected leader and deputy was angela if
i'd get covered if something happens to
me i need to put the mechanisms in place
for you to be able to take over that is
a sign of respect for my role and my
states in this organization
i think it's important that and it's an
important point here men
can be feminists and support women in
their career choices and support them
whether in the in the workplace as
yourself and others or actually by
supporting them soft or hard in terms of
how they can bring them forward but
that's an important role for men as well
as
putting themselves let's just deal with
let's let's just deal very quickly if we
may and last question
in supporting women
how can women in britain trust labour to
support women
when labour cannot even guarantee
the safety and gain the confidence of
its own woman mps
rosie duffield is not here because she
does not feel safe
yeah and that is a concern of mine that
rosie didn't feel safe to attend
conference but let me let me say
something about trev this trevor because
it's really serious and it crosses all
political parties what i have been
shocked by especially my female
colleagues and that's conservative
female mps as well is the level of
misogynistic abuse they get i've had
death threats many so many of them i
thought it was just because i've become
deputy leader the labour party that it
upped on a scale nothing but speaking to
colleagues across the house
their level of abuse women within your
level of abuse is disgusting and it has
to stop and you know
lindsay hoyle the speaker of the house
spoke about this as well he made it a
big key issue at his g7 meeting we need
to make sure that our politics means
that we can have the discourse that i
have with boris and others that's right
but abuse at that level is completely
unacceptable and rosie deserves our full
support and protection against that and
she would get that if she'd come to
conference we would have risk assessed
and made sure that she had every bit of
support that she needed to be here and
anybody who abuses rosie duffield who is
a member of the labour party would go
through our formal complaints procedure
and i'd expect a robust response on it
angela thank you very much indeed thank
you
now cues at the petrol station may be
annoying for drivers but for governments
they spelled big
trouble and if there's also a hint that
the turkeys may not be ready for
christmas the jitters began to turn into
panic the prime minister returned from
new york trumpeting the end of a
glorious summer
but he and his ministers could now be
facing a winter of discontent
i'm joined now by the transport
secretary
grant schatz
good morning grant chaps is it fair to
scold motorists
when buying for panic buying when all
they're trying to do is to make sure
they can get to work tomorrow morning
yeah and i think the important thing to
know is within the country at the six
refineries and 47 storage facilities
there's plenty of fuel there's no
shortage of the fuel within the country
so the most important thing is actually
that if people carry on as they normally
would and fill up their cars when they
normally would then you won't have
queues and you won't have shortages at
the pump either so it's not like we
don't have the fuel in the current
country uh we do need to just ensure
that people are filling up when they
need to fill up rather than thinking i
better go and fill up now just in case i
need it next week or the week after
you've been telling people that all week
and it hasn't really made any difference
and actually people are queuing up and
in fact what they're now doing is
driving past empty uh stations which do
not have petrol so the reassurance is
it's all going to be okay
absolutely conflicts with people's
actual experience so let me ask you
again
is it
enough just to tell people don't panic
by when they know
that they cannot get petrol in their
cars and get to work tomorrow morning
now i think government has to also
provide the reassurance as well
otherwise as you say people will say
well i can see what's happening with my
own eyes and that's why this morning
we've done a big package of measures
they're short medium and long term
to
help alleviate the issues which actually
fundamentally come down to one thing
coronavirus uh has created massive
shortages of lorry drivers uh tanker
drivers uh throughout the world and
coronavirus stopped us from testing them
so we couldn't bring new drivers into
the marketplace during the lockdown so
what we've done is doubled the capacity
brought the army in which we've
announced today in order to carry out
more testing so those are short-term
things visas as well in order to plug
the gap between here and christmas and
the medium term boot camps to train more
people into what is now a much better
paid market apprenticeships and i'm
appealing uh today for a million drivers
who have hgv licenses some of whom have
left the market to come back in
attracted perhaps by those higher wages
and in the long term better truck stops
better paying conditions in an industry
which has traditionally been undercut
and hasn't been paying the salaries that
would attract enough people to the
industry so a big package of measures
which i hope will help to reassure
people that actually we've got plenty of
fuel if everyone buys it as they
normally would uh we won't be getting
queues at the petrol stations as well
well look let's let's deal with long
term in a moment but let's talk about
the short term you are issuing just uh 5
500
short term visas for chicken pluckers
and 5 000 for qualified hgv foreign
drivers the head of the european haulage
associations says
you haven't got a chance mate they are
not going to come for that money
this is really
uh
not going to solve the problem is it
they will not be turkeys for christmas
well i look i i don't agree in terms of
the scale of the um issue they've been
long-term systemic sure guy who the guy
who represents all the holy drivers you
want to you want to bring back he's
telling you the money is not enough and
by the way our domestic uh halley's boss
is saying we need 90 000. 5 000 barely a
drop in the ocean yeah so logistics uk
who are actually the uk's biggest uh
haulage representative organization have
very much work on the package this
morning and do say that it's a
significant uh package it's not just of
course those visas which is very
short-term uh it's also the big
bottleneck is there are plenty of people
who know how to drive a lorry but where
they need to get tested or retested
dvsa that's the testing agency has had
this massive restriction now you might
say why haven't you acted on that
postcovid in fact we have we reopened
that testing back in april we've managed
to double the capacity partly by using
freedoms that we've got outside of the
eu to change the way the driving tests
work to get more capacity to get more
tests through bringing in the army will
be a very significant assistance there
as well and that way we can get more
people tested onto the roads so the
visas is only one element of it a
testing is very much uh front and center
and then of course this appeal for
people who can already drive to sort of
to realize actually the salaries now for
driving uh lorries has gone up
tremendously we think that's a good
thing we think they've been too many
years of people being undercut
to do a decent day's work and the fact
that people will get paid properly in
this industry is something which will
help it in the long term and it's
actually what's required to have this
industry sustainable in the long term
without constantly having to import
labor uh which is what's happened up
till now
can i put you why people in the industry
are
pretty cross about this they say it's
all too little too late even in the
press release you yourself put out the
boss of the food and drink um
uh confederation
says this is something uk food and drink
manufacturers has asked for have asked
for over the last few months what
they're basically saying is they've been
telling you for months this is going to
happen and you did nothing
not true uh we have already doubled well
it's in your press release
i'm not making it up it's in your press
release
as i say we've already doubled uh the
capacity so it's just not true that
nothing's been done and let's not
present this is sort of you know some uk
specific problem it's not in europe the
some of the for example in poland the
shortage is 123 000 drivers so there
isn't just one simple new point of that
itself there isn't one simple solution
to this but we have despite having had
shortages managed to ensure that petrol
was still getting to petrol stations
food store getting to the shops i'm
afraid there has been some pretty
irresponsible and briefing out by one of
the road haulage associations which has
helped to spark a crisis and that's very
very unhelpful it's counterproductive
and i know that they're desperate to
have more uh
european drivers undercutting british
salaries and that's been their their
their our school along we actually think
that you know it's important that this
country can train people that people can
do a proper day's work that they're paid
properly for that work and that the
long-term solution cannot be
undercutting british salaries uh and
having a constant cycle a vicious cycle
where you never get out of that problem
and not being able to train people here
and employ them here on decent salaries
isn't it
forgive me transport secretary isn't it
a little shabby to be blaming everybody
else when actually this arises a choice
you yourself made on august 5th you
wrote a group of mps
saying and i'm quoting from your letter
i do not support using foreign labor to
tackle a long-standing issue in the
haulage industry you were very specific
that you did not want this to happen you
made a choice
isn't it a little shabby now to be
basically saying oh it's everybody
else's fault when you made that choice
no just once again let me say i do not
believe as i said in that letter that
the long-term solution to britain's
shortages of hgv drivers is to say the
only choice we have is to import
european drivers undercut british
salaries
and not skill up people to do the job
here in the united kingdom so that's
absolutely right i also recognize i'm
completely pragmatic about this uh that
we need to ensure that people
are reassured now that this uh
rather sort of
manufactured situation has been created
because as i say there's not petrol in
the country it's it's uh it's if
everyone goes and guides you on the same
thing
hang on hang on
when you say yes manufactured when you
say this manufactured situation
manufactured by whom how well as i say
there was a meeting that took place
about 10 days ago
a private
a private meeting in which one of the
haulage associations decided to leak the
details to
uh to to to the media and that has
created as we have seen uh quite a large
degree of of concern people naturally
react to those things the the good news
is as i say there is plenty of fuel the
bad news is if everyone carries on
buying it when they don't need it then
you would continue to have uh cues
sooner or later everyone's cars will be
more or less filled up and there won't
be anywhere else to put fuel it's not
like um say the toilet roll crisis at
the beginning of the pandemic where
people could sort of stockpile it it's
very difficult to do that with with fuel
um and so it will come to an end but we
just appeal to people to uh be sensible
fill up when you normally would we've
got this big package in place
today in order to help alleviate the
pressure and we ask people to do their
part now we've got this packaging place
doing its part
some people in your own party are pretty
unhappy about this what they're saying
is
you've rolled over on driver shortages
and
changed
relaxed immigration
rules
so
when you next get
an appeal from farmers about fruit
rotting in the fields or
hospitality bosses about the fact that
they can't hire chefs and waiters
and care homeowners about lack of staff
are you all gonna roll over again
well it very much supports the point i'm
making which is we don't want to be in a
situation where we are not training
people here and in each of these cases
we need to look to the sectors involved
to make sure we are
they are training up the next
generations and you know in in julia
drivers for example um it's uh
99 male
uh it's uh average age 55. you know
there is a systemic problem that the
government is very keen to work with the
sector on but the sector will also need
to
help recruit people in and train people
and help improve standards in those in
those sectors so that it's more pleasant
to drive and then in other sectors as
you say they're already schemes that
enable people to come in to pick fruits
it's a seasonal it's a seasonal role but
yes broadly speaking as you suggest we
believe that we should be training
people in this country and that people
should be able to earn a decent wage in
this country and that is absolutely at
the heart of the government's uh
approach which is why even with the visa
to drive lorries it's limited until
christmas
okay um the deputy leader of the labour
party
had a colorful description of
conservatives um at a party yesterday
evening and she spoke to me this morning
and she made clear that what she really
had in mind was not
all conservative voters or indeed all
conservatives just the cabinet uh
are you okay to be described as scum
i just see it absolutely appalling
there's just no place in public life for
that sort of language that sort of
behavior
i saw that she had described uh herself
as being somebody who wanted to see a
kinder kind of politics uh back in 2019
and i'm very sorry that seems to have
disappeared i watched your interview and
and literally wondered to myself she
talking about me here i i'm just not
clear
and i think it would have been uh i was
talking about really
i wasn't sure but i'd be much i think
it'd be befitting if she actually just
apologized rather than talked around the
subject
we're coming up to uh cop 26 uh just
very one quick point because this is
really
in your bailiwick um
if we want to get to net zero
we are going to have to stop people
using fossil fuels um will you be
recommending to the chancellor that in
his autumn statement
he raises fuel duty
well the the as you'd expect me to say
in his awesome statement he'll have a
lot of decisions to take and i'm not
going to preempt his budget but
i'm just asking this because this is
your job would you say to him
here's something you could do
offer an option
as i say he'll have to come up with
decisions about his awesome budget but
what i can tell you is actually a lot of
people are already switching to electric
actually because of the crisis this
weekend i was just checking the latest
numbers there are 700 000 cars in
britain today uh with plugs on the end
of them uh who will not therefore be
involved in the in the petrol um
shortage a lot of people are already
switching and in eight years time
there's the end of the pure the sale of
pure petrol and diesel cars uh in any
case so that that movement across is
already taking place we've got a very
big uh transport decarbonization plan in
place which actually uh helps to track
us along that path to zero carbon in in
cars but and then critically in the much
harder to decarbonize parts for
transport which uh you know ships but
planes in particular and this country is
leading the way for example with
hydrogen aircraft being tested out at
the moment
gran chaps thank you very much indeed
you're welcome
now secure sakirstama's attempt to forge
a new path for labour got off to a
pretty shaky start this weekend and if
anyone thought that the party's left
wingers would go without a fight they've
never met any of the jeremy corbyn fan
club in fact the party's former leader
let fly a couple of days ago accusing
the current leadership of propping up
capitalism to be clear he thinks that's
a bad thing let's see what his brother
in arms former shadow chancellor john
mcdonald thinks uh john mcdonald you
described kierstarma's essay
uh published this week the road ahead
uh as the sermon on the mount composed
by a focus group
that's a bit disrespectful to your
leader isn't it
don't worry k
here's a friend of mine he can take it
on the chin i was trying to get across
to him that we've got to go beyond
banalities we need real
real vision and policy program now and
that's why we that's what this
conference should all be about the real
concrete policies we're going to pursue
do you think that um
the labour policy offer that's being
made
uh
is
familiar to you i mean i i was talking
to ander rain this morning the attack on
private schools frankly the new deal for
working people feels pretty much like a
mcdonald deal for working people on the
new deal for working people um angie and
andy mcdonald the shadow secretary of
state in blunt
andy's been working on it for nearly
three years two and a half years at
least it's a great piece of work and
lord john hendy as well angie's fronted
that which is great so a lot of it is
building upon what we did um i think it
needs to go a bit further in terms of
pay levels not the 10 pounds i think
it's 15 pounds now we should be going
but my anxiety yesterday this is why i
i wrote a couple of pieces for the press
this weekend is that
that got drowned out by all this falling
out over the constitutional rules of our
party re we had really two good
announcements this weekend one was angel
rayner and andy mcdonald's employment
policy but the other one was lucifer's
housing policy both terrific both in the
the trajectory of what we've been doing
over recent years but that that got
completely drowned out by the
shenanigans over our constitution really
are you going to accept the compromise
uh that has been reached on the rules is
everybody going to go okay fine i don't
think people are happy still on the
electoral college
kia pushed that unnecessarily got
defeated
then he's pushed this threshold for um
nominations from mps the next leader who
goes on the ballot paper he got defeated
on that and got that got amended i don't
think actually we need a change in the
rule but if it goes through to be honest
we'll work with it it won't prevent the
left wing coming forward as long as i'm
concerned but i don't think it's
necessary i would oppose it this morning
if i had a vote definitely you would
oppose it yeah
do you think it's going to go through by
the way today i think it'd be touch and
go to be honest i can't predict that at
all um part of the problem is is that
we've had quite a number of clp
delegates excluded over the last few
days and again that's an issue i'm
worried about so the clp delegations
have been weakened i think they're the
strongest in opposition because they
want the members to have a full range of
candidates to choose from when there's
the next leadership election and by the
way you know i what's the rush about
changing the rules for
nominating a leo voting for a leader
we're not gonna have a leadership
election as far as i'm aware unless
people know something i don't i'm trying
to get a sense of mcdonald of where you
really are on kierstama um
policy wise he seems to be doing all the
things that you would have done and
would feel happy with um
maybe there's a stumble here and there
on the constitution but you should be
happy with this guy he's a democratic
elected leader he won the election 18
months ago that's the first point so you
have to respect that and i have done
the second point is on the
constitutional changes he never said a
word about that when he stood for lead
and i think that's he should have done
if he was going to change our
constitutional rules he should have said
it then and that opens him up to charges
of not being
straight with people when he stood for
this so i'm worried about that in terms
of policy we haven't heard much at all
so that's why this conference i was
urging him concentrate on policy
concentrate on getting that vision
across rather than dragging us through
this mess of a rankle and argument about
faction fighting over the rules i i
don't want to keep as somebody said
yesterday wanging on about the
constitution but
do you go with the people who say that
if he's going to bring forward this kind
of thing
actually and as you say he didn't
mention it in his uh
run for leadership that he should stand
again i i've said he should have gone
back to the people he should either
consulted or studied a new leadership
election if necessary but i would i said
that why don't you follow what other
leaders have done gone through a proper
conscious consensation ed miliband even
had a special conference don't try and
bounce the party like this on i want to
get on to policy and what i'm saying to
you on policy look at biden look at
biden a centrist leader which was what
care really is
but he's worked with the left and all
wings of his party and he's brought
forward a radical political program
follow that path and i think it'll take
us back into the government
do you think that the
idea of bringing forward these rule
changes
speak to something deeper the sense that
and um
maybe i'm about to compliment you the
sense that the sense that the center of
the labour party
has decided that actually the membership
has changed
quite decisively and it can't
trust the labour party's member as
membership as it currently is and
therefore it needs to operate in a
different way i think look you've struck
a raw now that that's quite right i
think there are some people maybe around
here as well i don't think it's cure
himself but there might be some people
around here who have a pathological fear
of democracy and of our members yet look
we have a large amount a huge membership
unfortunately it's declining at the
moment because people are getting a bit
demoralized but we have a huge
membership they reflect the wider
community you know the doctors the
nurses the
people working in the public sector
lorry drivers and all the rest trust the
people that's what i'm saying to them so
don't have these shenanigans where
you're trying to restrict the role of
members in fact when kier stood for
leader he said he was going to engage
with members more and members would have
more of a role that's why people feel
this is a bit of a step backwards and
he's not he hasn't been really straight
so we're saying to him look get back on
track forget these rule changes get on
with the discussion about policy and
let's have a real discussion
the employment stuff was great lucy
powell's housing stuff was terrific
there's a lot more to go for now as well
in terms of the public schools vat that
was one of our policies but you know we
had a wider policy which was bringing
public schools into the states
we were going to integrate them into the
public sector and that would have
eventually meant there was no need for
their existence
isn't isn't the problem here john
mcdonnell that
what kirsten wants to do
is to focus the labour party on what
labor voters think
rather than what labour activists who
have a lot of time to go to meetings and
uh argue uh the
the argue that toss over this composite
and that composite and that what he's
trying to do with this is to move the
party over to thinking about
labor voters as opposed to labor members
there's always that issue about a
political party's membership sort of
isolating it to the wider community that
might happen if you had a small romp of
a party when you've got half a million
members that's impossible to do that
means we've got virtually a member on
every street but the key issue as well
is how do you further engage those
members in the wider community right
through community organizing all of
those issues and again the community
organizing team has been laid off and
sacked completely unnecessary so when
kia said i want to engage with members
more i want members to have more of
engagement the party we thought it was
going down the path of making sure we
broadened the membership i was aiming
for a million members we should be doing
at recruiting recruiting all the time
but opening up our doors that people all
have a say over the development those
policies as soon as you start closing
that down for example restricting their
ability to select the leader or have a
vote over the leader effective vote of
the leader then you're cutting yourself
out for the wider community um would you
have used the words that angela rainer
used last night
have you not heard some of my speeches
trevor it's important sometimes i'm
embarrassed they are
well we've all been there we've all been
there late at night getting very angry
about what's going on what i like about
andrew rayner is that she's human she
acts she may well drop herself in it
just as i've done time and time again
but she built she's human and she have
human emotions and when you get angry
about something sometimes the language
that you use might be over the top but
what she's angry about the issue we're
all angry about outlook let me just say
this trevor in my community at the
moment i've got large numbers of people
who are fearful because they're going to
lose 20 pounds off their universal
credit they're going to be thrust into
poverty with children no wonder she's
angry so sometimes your language gets
ahead of you but
deep down she's expressing the anger
that many of us feel so everybody now
gets a free pass to say what they like
about other people
because they get because they're a bit
you know they're a bit emotional no we
have to be late at night no we have to
be disciplined and all of us have to
bear that in mind we need to bring
people with us around turn them off but
we're expressing human emotion here and
sometimes you don't get the language
right and some instances though actually
people forgive you for that because they
know you're actually your intentions are
good all right well
a theme this morning has been civility
and respect and you've been
extremely respectful of of your leader
uh whatever your private feedings are
the new leader of unite sharon graham
announced that she wouldn't be coming to
conference even though it's her first
opportunity to demonstrate support for
secure a bit rude or not no not really
i've known sharon i've worked with
shannon over the years she's been
involved in some of the organizational
disputes in my constituency at heathrow
airport for example she's been brilliant
her job yeah but how hard could it be to
turn up for the leader's speech she's
got about 16 disputes going at the
moment her job is at the moment as she
sees it is to concentrate on her members
who are struggling in this environment
in this economic climate so i can
understand why she puts that as a
priority but she'll be engaged she's
look again what sharon has done
you're genuinely saying that coming down
to brighton for wednesday afternoon is
going to make the difference in any of
those 16 disputes i don't think it makes
sense this is a signal isn't it i don't
think it makes any difference to keel
whether individually i'm not saying it
makes a difference so what i'm saying is
the
union leaders
who are big figures in their own right
tend and historically have paid respect
to the leader of the labour party
and they turn up to his speech
you're not with the you're not with the
game what sharon is about no listen that
what sharon is about is saying i'm the
trade union general secretary but i'm a
member of a team her team is down here
as a delegation she has confidence in
them she's no longer boss politics i
have to order everything around what
she's doing is getting on with her job
as she sees it the priority and the
industrial struggles that our workers
are having their living stones their
fight to keep their jobs and to fight to
keep that protect their families that's
what she's concentrating on she said
i've got a good team in the delegation
there they'll manage all the decisions
that have taken place it's a democratic
union the positions have been taken by
the union number a number of issues that
delegation will vote calling it's
democracy
john mcdonnell thank you very much
uh the health and social care sectors
are facing a difficult winter cases are
stacked up into the millions
kobe isn't beaten
and now there's the awkward issue of
whether care workers should be compelled
to uh tap the jab as a condition of
employment and then there's the cut to
universal credit
at the centre of many of these tricky
issues are low-paid workers represented
by britain's biggest unit union unison
their general secretary christine mciner
is here and she joins me thank you very
much
for getting into the seat so quickly
um
the
the the conference is of course going to
be talking a lot about
this weekend's issues but i i want to um
besides welcoming you to sky news i
think it's first time you've been on
this program i i i want to start with
the issue
that is bread and butter for you um
there are 40 000 workers we think
probably in the health and social care
sector who have not been
vaccinated the government
or yet to be vaccinated the government
says that if people aren't vaccinated by
november they could lose their job
what's the union's position
on the government's
decision that vaccination should be a
condition of employment
uh we think it's wrong i think it's the
wrong thing to do and when we've been
speaking to our members who work in
social care and we're the biggest social
care union
the vast majority of them the majority
of them are vaccinated and we've we've
done everything we can as as unison to
say to them get vaccinated these are the
reasons why you should be vaccinated and
i think peer pressure can be a good way
in people giving them reassurance about
what happened when they got vaccinated
i think going down the compulsion route
is just counterproductive and people who
have genuinely got either conditions or
concerns about why they can't be
vaccinated or don't want to be
vaccinated at this point given where we
are in the pandemic they'll just leave
they'll
they'll you know they'll walk they'll
walk away from the job and we're not
unique in saying this so we're actually
it's the government to sort of step here
we're actually you know saying the same
thing as most of the providers are
saying uh and so we've said to the
government why are you doing it this way
there must be other things we can do the
sector's already in total crisis it
wasn't crisis before the pandemic which
just made it eve then the pandemic made
it so much worse
uh you know there's over 120 000
vacancies at the moment and it's just
well there'll be more unbelievable
there'll be more vacancy is now
presumably if people uh decide that they
will rather not work than have the jab
and this is at the beginning of the
winter now um
what is it that could be done about this
so what we've said to the government is
do more persuasion and actually find out
why people aren't getting vaccinated now
there may be some reasons why certain
people refuse to get vaccinated there is
still nervousness among groups and
you've got to give them full information
about why what happens when you get
vaccinated why it's a good thing to be
vaccinated
there are some kind of basic um
issues that you could deal with as well
so
many of them as you know trevor are low
paid workers many of them
don't get paid sick pay when they're
offset even with covert related
illnesses
and
they're worried if they go and get a job
and they're unwell for a few days or
even a week they're off sick they get no
pay
so that's one issue i'm not saying it's
the major issue but it's certainly one
issue making it easier for people to get
the job um
actually bringing them along with groups
with other workers to say this is what
happened when i got vaccinated this is
what this is what happened to me this is
why it's important there's lots of
persuasion you could do rather than
question so but of course right now
there are tens of thousands who
haven't even had the first jab and
unless the gap between first and second
jabs is
dramatically reduced they won't be in a
position by the november deadline if
that happens um
is that going to be a cause for
industrial action i mean how are you
going to resolve this so we are looking
at we're looking at we're looking at
legal advice and what we can do to
support our members we've got lots of
advice out there we've been contacting
them directly what we're saying and
we're talking to employers as well
saying let's see if we can find a way
through this is there something else we
can do
are there some other jobs they can be
put in in the meantime while we still
try and persuade people to get this done
that actually sacking people is not a
good idea because it may be that once
people have thought about it a bit more
they will come back but as you say if
they can't hit that that deadline then
that's it they're out
and so we're trying to say to them and
to the government let's be a bit more
flexible about this and i think there's
a terrible irony here and the government
are well aware of it which is every time
i've asked them can we do something
about lopey can we do something about
improving standards and training for
them they say can't do it christina we
have no levers because it's you know
it's all prime mainly private and
voluntary sector the government can use
levers when they want to do it because
they're clearly doing it for this okay
so we've got covered we've got uh the 20
uh 20 pound a week cut in universal
credit which affects a lot a lot of your
members um
you've said that you think that this
could be the year for industrial action
um now back in 1979 it was your union
the predecessor of unison that
essentially led
that winter of discontent are we heading
for another winter of discontent well
there's certainly a lot of discontent
out there
but whether it will turn into full-scale
industrial action i don't know that
would be for the for our members to
determine we are out for consultation at
the moment we've just been consulting on
the the nhs page
on industrial elections well an
indicative ballot it's called um so it's
not a formal industrial action ballot
which as you know is very restrictive
because of the legislation that we've
got
so we are but we're consulting across
loads of sectors so our local government
sector health sector our police staff
members
all being consulted on what they think
about the offer or lack of an offer that
they've been that they've been given um
where will it lead i don't know yet at
this point in time for example in the
nhs
uh
there are 16 trade unions and i used to
be the lead negotiator for those unions
so i know how difficult it is to get
consent is across them but that's the
aim is to actually talk to the other
unions in each of the sectors where
we're the main union and see how far we
can go down the road of getting some
consensus for
a plan of action shall we say going
forward
you are i think probably the first woman
leader of unison if i'm not mistaken 75
of your members are women that reflects
a wider
trend in the trade union movement which
is now
has more women members and
leader of the tc is a woman and so on
do you think that is going to lead to a
change in the tactics and indeed the
preoccupations the agenda of the trade
union movement
i think it will present a different
image of the trade union movement
without a doubt as in i think uh
people will see us perhaps differently
than you know
and i'm not
saying all leaders wear the kind of tub
thumping type of a traditional image of
of a trade union leader i mean right by
no means our are the male trade union
leaders all like that but
to interrupt you but it's very
interesting the i think probably the
best-selling novel of the the the year
uh richard osmond the thursday murder
club has uh you've read it and it has a
guy in it who is a retired trade union
leader who is probably a mix of i don't
know ron tarden
the the old tng
leader um do you think that those days
are over for that guy
uh
yeah i mean i think especially because
of the membership and it varies across
unions i mean i just look at my own
union in unison as you say 75 women a
big percentage of hers do jobs like
care workers or their nurses or their
health care assistants or uh you know
the the their
control room staff within police and and
uh
ambulance centers you know there's a
huge range of jobs cleaners caterers etc
and i don't mean they're not militant i
don't mean they're not um passionate
about their rights but i think they have
a different way of expressing it in a
sense
and so that old image of you know a male
of a you know a man in a in a donkey
jacket or a high-vis vest standing
around a brazier i mean
uh
that's not where our members are our
members will take strike actually our
members will pick it they will do they
will you know stand and demonstrate
against unfairness and injustice but i
think they expect the leaders to
be able to
uh negotiate to talk sensibly and
express arguments on their behalf and at
the end of the day they pay us as their
officials to get deals that's what my
members asked me to do so
megaphones out out thank you christy
mcinerney thank you
now
we've been talking about the way that
the labour party is trying to navigate
its way on the path back to power in a
landscape with echoes of the 1970s and
the 1980s
delegates could do worse than listen to
some of the parties elder states people
including our next guest charles clark
was a labour councillor worked as chief
of staff to neil kinnick in opposition
became an mp himself and served as
education secretary and home secretary
under tony blair
you could say he's seen it and done it
all
and he joins us now
charles clark
how do you think they're doing so far
this weekend well first of all trevor
good morning nice to see you in the
fresh sunday morning i think they're
doing okay i think politics has been
exceptionally difficult in the time of
covid this is the first really large
person-to-person gathering that's taken
place
there are many many issues which need to
be resolved uh on some of them you've
covered in this program today
but i think they've put themselves up as
a realistic alternative to the
conservatives and that's what they need
to be at this stage they need to take it
further now to really set out what the
alternatives are there's more work to do
well i want to come to that but if i may
first
deal with the the issue of the moment
you
were have been you were a minister for a
long time this weekend the country faces
a petrol crisis prospectus shortages in
the supermarket um
you
actually faced a rather more challenging
christ set of crises at home at home
secretary a few duty crisis foot and
mouth and when you were party chairman
so on um what would you be advising the
cabinet to be doing right now
get real look at the absolute situation
in a sense grant schapp's got off a bit
light he's the puppet and the puppet
master the organ grinder is pretty patel
the home secretary the whole issue here
is about the immigration criteria and
under what basis you can give people the
right to work in this country brexit
made the decision clear it wasn't the eu
it was the british government so the
question is could this have been
predicted well yes it could you gave
earlier today the example of branch
chaps himself predicting it in august so
if it could be predicted why didn't the
steps weren't steps in place earlier
secondly why is it so few we're talking
about 4 000 or so
road drivers when they're 100 000
drivers short when we've got 13 000
drivers less than when we were last in
the eu from the eu and then finally why
only these sectors why only
road drivers and poultry what about care
workers you've been talking to christina
just now they're significant shortages
across the economy the government has it
in its power to resolve those questions
right now and pretty patellars held out
to say no change no change no change no
change until yesterday morning when the
prime minister overruled her and said
they put in the scheme that they're
announcing this morning too little too
late you've got to face up to the issue
predict it get on the case beforehand
and then pull out all the stops at the
moment the government isn't pulling out
any stops at all it's it's various
injunctions as to how people should
behave but the reality is when we had
those issues in autumn 2000 on the field
drivers dispute the foot and mouth
crisis we pulled out all the stops at
that time whatever problem was needed
including up to and including using the
army if necessary to help move things
forward i don't see any evidence that
grant traps himself or his organ grinder
priti patel are taking these issues at
all seriously do you think that's the
core point do you think pretty patella
is up to it of course she isn't she's
been a hopeless home secretary and she
should have been sat the last time
around all the commentators just a
couple of weeks ago all the commentators
rightly say that she's got some grip on
boris johnson he's frightened of her in
the back benches or whatever it might be
which means she's unstackable as far as
boris johnson's concerned but her track
record is appalling it was appalling
through covid uh in the whole way she
dealt with policing the civil liberties
issued through covid it's appalling on
immigration crossing the uh channel it's
appalling on this issue now she is the
person who has the responsibility for
the quotas of people allowed to get
visas in this country and on what basis
it is she's deciding that she's been
overruled by the prime minister for this
short announcement we've got this
morning
but she is the person who's responsible
and people like grant chaps aren't
pulling the calling the tricks at all
they're simply uh doing what she said
let's come back to labour you were neil
kinnick's chief of staff
um at the time when the now very famous
speech uh denouncing militant uh
okay took took place or delivered that
that speech and you in fact had been
in liverpool trying to
deal with the problem as you saw it of
the far left the militant and so on now
it's pretty clear that the party
leadership wants to try to tackle
a similar problem now if you were neil
kinnick's chief of staff now what would
you be a neil king a big problem
kirsten's chief of staff now what would
you be advising him to do firstly you
have to prepare in each case in each
area it's policy it's organization it's
communication you have to prepare that's
what we did on liverpool for that speech
about militant that that you referred to
with neil that applies to the
constitutional changes we're talking
about i'm in favor of what's going to go
through today i hope because i think
it's a step in the right direction i
think he's done well to put it on the
agenda but you've got to prepare very
fully and very comprehensively you can't
just bounce it on everybody
secondly the outstanding issues that
still remain a large number of
disciplinary cases in the labour party
about anti-semitism and so on thousands
i gather still unresolved i would say
those have to be resolved and sorted out
categorically they can't hang about in
all of these issues as they have to move
forward that's on the organizational
side on the policy side you have to
develop in each area of policy an
alternative of what we would be doing we
labor would be doing were we in
government now so it's no good simply
attacking opposing by attacking the
government and saying you're a load of
rubbish they are a load of rubbish but
that's not enough you've got to say if
we were there we'd be doing this in a
different way whether it's the migration
dispute whether it was what we're
talking about today the fuel drivers
dispute or whatever on every area we
have to say to the british people there
is a better way of doing this uh dealing
with this problem and we would be doing
it in this way on cop26 when it comes
around on security the foreign policy
issues whatever it is and that has to
emerge
weakly as it comes through it's not a
great policy for the future it's a sense
of what the labor alternative is we get
a sense of that i get the sense that um
you don't think that actually that's
what we're getting this weekend instead
what we are probably going to get is 24
hours of conversation about
the word scum now you've just used the
word rubbish about government
do you think that that kind of language
helps in any way
in general no and i try and censor
myself sometimes sometimes
unsuccessfully on those kinds of things
but i i don't think that's the right way
to proceed but i think it is fair for an
opposition to say is the government
competent in dealing with this question
so in the case of what we're just
talking about now is the government
competent in dealing with the migration
issue with the fuel dispute issue or
whatever if it's not competent we should
draw attention to but this is a but this
is uh i'm really really
asking a question about the way that
politics is projected
um this is going to hang over the labour
leadership for some time isn't it
is the deputy leader a person that you
can trust to put out there
she certainly is i i think it may hang
over it depends what people like you and
how people like you talk about it i
wasn't aware about till i heard it you
mentioned on this program today it's not
an enormous issue
as i'm sure andrew herself would say
today it's not the right way to conduct
yourself in these circumstances and
she'd seek to
control herself in a way that ensured
that bad language of that kind or my use
of the word rubbish is not used uh
because that's a bad way of conducting
politics but i don't think it's the
central question the central question is
what are the policies government
actually doing and what should labour be
or offering as an alternative charles
clark thank you very much thank you
that's it from me this week there will
be much more from the labour conference
in a moment we'll be talking to uh sam
coates in the take uh to an analyze what
we've heard this morning so coming up
after the break
the legendary sam coat
[Music]
you